سته اشهر مرت على احتجاز السلطات
الايرانيه المواطنه الفرنسيه سيسيل كوليرو
وصديقها جاكباري عدم تقدم القضيه دفع
عائلتها الى الخروج عن الصمت للمره الاولى
في نادي الصحافه في مدينه ستراسبرج شرقيه
فرنسا
وبمشاعر ممزوجه بالدموع والامل اعلنت نومي
شقيقه سيسي الاطلاق لجنه دعم لها
ونعول على الاعلام لفعل ذلك نتمنى ان تعلم
اننا ندعمها هنا في فرنسا وان يساعدها ما
نقوم به على الصمود نحن نحاول ان ندافع عن
صورتها وان يوفر شروط مناسبه لتستاني في
حياتها عندما تحصل على حريتها
التي يمكن ان تطرق لاطلاق سراحها في ظل
احتجاجا تصفه فرنسا بالابتزاز همم
يلعبون اي دوله في ظل تجاه في حق الدفاع
بل احتقاره لذا لا يوجد مجالا للتحرك
الدبلوماسيه والاعلام نامل منكم ان
تساهموا بتشكيل حركه ضغط شعبيه وقوي اكثر
ما اثار قلق العائله واصدقاء السيسي كان
الاعترافات التي بثتها سلطات الايرانيه عن
ان الرهينه الفرنسيه جاسوسه تعمل لصالح
استخبارات بلدها في وقت تقول العائله انها
كانت في ايران للسياحه في بلد كانت تحلم
بزيارته واعتقلت على الطريق وهي متوجهه
الى المطار في طريق العوده الى فرنسا
لقد فقدت وزنها وصوتها كان يرتجف نعم كانت
هناك اشارات واضحه انها في وضع نفسي صعب
وتامل
سته الاخرين المحتجزين في ايران للانضمام
الى هذا التحرك املا في تشكيل ضغط
دبلوماسي يقود للافراج عنهم العربيه